MINI MONOLOGUE.
FIRST WE GET STARTED WITH
OUR BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
♪ A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS.
WE WILL GO SLOW.
A LOT OF DETAILS SURROUNDING
THIS DEMOCRATIC MEMO PUT
TOGETHER BY LIBERAL
TRUMP-HATING CONGRESSMAN
ADAM SCHIFF.
NOW, WE WILL DISSECT THIS
THING POINT BY POINT.
WE WILL GIVE YOU ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT THE MEDIA
WENT TELL YOU ABOUT.
BEFORE WE GET INTO ALL OF
THOSE DETAILS.
HERE IS THE BIGGEST TAKE
AWAY.
EVERYTHING FROM A YEAR AGO
THAT WE HAVE BEEN UNCOVERING
AND TELLING YOU ABOUT
INVOLVING RAMPANT FISA
ABUSES, SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, HAS ACTUALLY NOW
BEEN CORROBORATED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
NOW, IT'S ALL TRUE, THE
SCHIFF MEMO WAS SUPPOSED TO
TAKE ON THE CREDIBILITY AND
CHALLENGE THE MEMO THAT
CONGRESSMAN NUNES PUT OUT.
IN REALITY, THE EXACT
OPPOSITE IS HAPPENING.
NOW, HERE'S WHY.
FACTS ARE FACTS.
THE TRUTH IS THE TRUTH.
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW CONFIRMING
THAT THE COMPLETELY
UNVERIFIED KILLERRY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES
MADE A LARGE PART OF THE
FISA APPLICATION THAT WAS
USED TO THEN SPY ON A MEMBER
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HERE IS ANOTHER KEY POINT
YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THE NEAR
RADIO SILENCE FROM FAKE NEWS
CNN, CONSPIRACY TV, MSNBC
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SCHIFF
MEMO?
THE LIBERAL MEDIA THEY ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT IT PROVES ALL
OF THE DEFININGS AND FACTS
OF THE REPUBLICAN MEMOS.
AND NOW THAT YOU HAVE THAT
IMPORTANT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION.
LET'S DIVE INTO THIS
DEMOCRATIC MEMO.
HERE'S WHAT THIS SCHIFF MEMO
CORROBORATES.
JUST LIKE THE NUNES MEMO IN
THE HOUSE GRASSLEY GRAHAM
MEMO IN THE SENATE.
THEY LAY OUT THE FBI, THE
DOJ DID IN FACT LIE AND
MISLEAD A FISA JUDGE ABOUT
THE FACT THAT HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC THAT SHE
CONTROLLED ACTUALLY PAID FOR
THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER FULL OF
LIVES.
NOW, SCHIFF, HE ACTUALLY
QUOTES A SECTION OF THE FISA
APPLICATION IN HIS MEMO.
READS THAT THE DOJ DISCLOSED
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS
APPROACHED BY AN IDENTIFIED
U.S. PERSON WHO HAS
INDICATED A SOURCE ONE
STEELE, THAT A U.S.-BASED
LAW FIRM HAD HIRED THE
IDENTIFIED U.S. PERSON TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH REGARDING
CANDIDATE NUMBER ONE'S TIES
TO RUSSIA.
TRUMP.
THE IDENTIFIED PERSON AND
SOURCE NUMBER ONE HAVE
LONG-STANDING BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP.
NOW, THE IDENTIFIED U.S.
PERSON HIRED SOURCE NUMBER
ONE TO CONDUCT THE RESEARCH.
THE IDENTIFIED U.S. PERSON
NEVER ADVISED SOURCE NUMBER
ONE AS TO THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND THE RESEARCH INTO
CANDIDATE ONE'S, TRUMP'S
TIES TO RUSSIA.
THE FBI SPECULATES THE
IDENTIFIED U.S. PERSON WAS
LIKELY LOOKING FOR
INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
USED TO DISCREDIT CANDIDATE
NUMBER ONE'S CAMPAIGN.
MOSTLY
HISTLY
HILLLY
HILLARY CLINTON, THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, THE DNC.
HERE'S THE SHOCK.
THEY ARE NEVER MENTIONED.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE
OUTRIGHT LYING BY OMISSION.
SLOWLY.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT IS AN
INDISPUTABLE FACT THAT THE
FBI, DOJ, LIED TO THE FISA
JUDGE IN ORDER TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE.
HE WILL JOIN US LATER,
CARTER PAGE THEY
PURPOSEFULLY AND MALICIOUSLY
HID ALL TIES TO CLINTON AND
THE DNC BECAUSE THERE IS NO
WAY ON THIS GREEN EARTH THAT
ANY FISA JUDGE WOULD EVER
HAVE APPROVED THE
APPLICATION IF IN FACT THE
JUDGE KNEW THAT CLINTON AND
THE DNC PAID OVER
$12 MILLION FOR A DOSSIER TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
AND THAT LAST SENTENCE ABOUT
THE FBI SPECULATING ABOUT
THE PURPOSE OF THE DOSSIER,
THAT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT,
THAT INDICATES THAT THE FBI
AND THE DOJ THEY KNEW ABOUT
THE POLITICAL SMOTE
INVESTIGATIONS BEHINDTH
RUSSIAN PAID FOR DOSSIER AND
THEY USED IT ANY WAY.
THAT KEY POINT HAB
PRE-SEASON AND UNDOUBTEDLY
TRUE UNDERSTAND HOW PROFOUND
THIS IS, THE FBI AND DOJ NEW
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
AND THEY PAID FOR A DOSSIER
FILLED WITH RUSSIAN LIES AND
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES THEY
COVERED UP THE FACT BEFORE
THE FISA JUDGE TO GET THE
WARRANT AND IN THE PROCESS
WHAT ARE THEY REALLY DOING?
THEY ARE SHREDDING THE
CONSTITUTION.
FOURTH AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS.
SCHIFF IS ALSO EXPOSING
HIMSELF TO BE A BIG FAT
LIAR.
IN THIS MEMO ADMITS THAT THE
DOSSIER HAD POLITICAL
MOTIVATIONS.
BUT ON FEBRUARY 2ND, AFTER
THE NUNES MEMO CAME OUT,
SCHIFF PUT OUT A STATEMENT
THAT STATEMENT READS IN
PART, QUOTE:  THE MAJORITY
SUGGESTS THAT THE FBI FAILED
TO ALERT THE COURT AS TO
MR. STEELE'S POTENTIAL
POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS AND
THE POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS OF
THOSE WHO HIRED HIM.
THIS IS INACCURATE.
SO SCHIFF IS SAYING
SOMETHING THAT IS AN
OUTRIGHT LIE.
THERE IS THE PROOF THE
SCHIFF MEMO IS COOPERATING
THE NUNES AND GRASSLEY MEMOS
BECAUSE THEY EXPOSE HOW THE
DOSSIER WAS THE ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE FISA
APPLICATION.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GRASSLEY GRAHAM MEMO, IT
FINDS, QUOTE:  THEIR WORDS,
THE BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION CONSISTED OF THE
UNVERIFIED CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
WOW.
NOW SCHIFF TRIES TO DOWN
PLAY THE DOSSIER BY WRITING
IN HIS MEMO THAT IT ONLY
MADE UP A NARROW PART OF THE
FISA APPLICATION.
SCHIFF ALSO WRITES THAT A
SPECIFIC SECTION OF THE FISA
APPLICATION ACTUALLY
REFERENCES THE COMPLETELY
UNVERIFIED CLAIMS IN THE
DOSSIER ABOUT CARTER PAGE
AND JUNE 20TH, JUNE 2016 AND
THE MEETINGS THAT HE HAD IN
MOSCOW.
PAGE HAS DENIED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN IT'S NEVER BEEN
CONFIRMED.
SCHIFF IS ADMITTING CONTRARY
TO ITS CLAIMS THAT THE FISA
MADE UP TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT.
CURRENT POSITION ON DOSSIER
TRYING TO MINIMIZE IT
COMPLETE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING BACK IN
MARCH DURING A CONGRESSIONAL
HEARING THIS IS ALL
POLITICS.
THEY ARE ALL LIARS AND THEY
ARE ALL PHONY AND WE HAVE
BEEN RIGHT FOR A YEAR NOW
FORMER BRITISH INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER WHO IS REPORTEDLY
HELD IN HIGH REGARD BY U.S.
INTELLIGENCE.
RUSSIAN SOURCES TELL HIM
THAT PAGE HAS ALSO HAD A
SECRET MEETING WITH --
ACCORDING TO STEELE'S
RUSSIAN SOURCES PAGE OFFERED
BROKERAGE FEES ALSO
ACCORDING TO STEELE'S RUST
SOURCES THE CAMPAIGN IS
OFFERED DOCUMENTS DAMAGING
TO HILLARY CLINTON.
ACCORDING TO STEELE, IT WAS
MANAFORT WHO CHOSE PAGE WHO
SERVE AS A GO BETWEEN FOR
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIAN INTERESTS.
MY FOCUS TODAY IS TO EXPLORE
HOW MANY CLAIMS WITHIN
STEELE'S DOSSIER ARE LOOKING
MORE AND MORE LIKELY AS
THOUGH THEY ARE ACCURATE.
THE REPUTATION OF THE
AUTHOR, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
IS A FORMER ACCOMPLISHED
CAREER BUILT ON RUSSIA IS
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO RUN A
SOURCE AND NOT SOMEONE
WITHOUT CONTACTS.
>> Sean: THEY KNOW BETTER.
ANDY MCCARTHY AND OTHER
LEGAL EXPERTS ARE POINTING
TO A VERY KEY FACT
NORTHBOUND TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT APPROVED.
PAGE WILL JOIN NEWS A
MINUTE.
PAGE WAS ACTING AS AN AGENT
OF A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
>> HELP RUSSIA OR LIKELY
THAT VIOLATION OF FEDERAL
LAW.
NOW AS WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING ON.
THE DOSSIER PUT THE FISA
WARRANT OVER THE TOP.
SIGN OFF ON THE WARRANT.
WE HAVE ALSO BEEN TELLING
YOU THAT THE FISA
APPLICATION.
FIRST AND PROBABLY THE
SECOND TIME.
THEN IN THE DOSSIER WAS
HELPED WIN APPROVAL.
SMANGEG, IT WAS THE BULK OF
IT AND PROBABLY WHY THE
NUNES MEMO SAYS THAT THE
FORMER DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE, HE TESTIFIED
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, A JUDGE
WOULD NEVER HAVE GRANTED A
FISA WARRANT TO SURVEIL
CARTER PAGE AND BY THE WAY
NUNES MEMO WAS RELEASED.
DEMOCRATS OPPOSE NUNES ABOUT
LYING MCCABE'S TESTIMONY ON
THE DOSSIER.
INTERESTING, THE SCHIFF MEMO
DOESN'T OFFER UP ANY
EVIDENCE TO REFUTE THAT
WRONG, WHY WOULDN'T SCHIFF
AND THE DEMOCRATS PROVIDE A
TRANSCRIPT WHAT MCCABE SAID
TO PROVE THE POINT.
MY SOURCES TOLD ME MCCABE
SAID THAT AND MUCH MORE.
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T DO IT THE
FOR THE OBVIOUS REASON.
THE FACT AREN'T ON THEIR
SIDE.
MAKE BIG DEAL ABOUT
CREDIBILITY.
HE WORKED FOR THE FBI.
SCHIFF IS TRYING TO CHANGE
THE SUBJECT HERE AND HIDE
THE FACT THAT STEELE USED
CURRENT AND FORMER RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT SOURCES IN THE
DOSSIER.
AND THAT NONE OF THE
INFORMATION, THIS IS THE
POSH PART.
NONE OF IT WAS EVER VERIFIED
BY THE FBI.
IT WAS NEVER VERIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, BY
FUSION GPS WHICH HIRED
STEELE.
FISA WARRANT, THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE PERSON IS
NOT NEARLY AS IMPORTANT AS
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE
SOURCES OR WHERE THE
INFORMATION IS COMING FROM.
AS WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU
NONE OF THE INFORMATION FROM
RUSSIAN SOURCES WAS EVER
CORROBORATED.
NONE OF IT.
THIS MODERN FACT FROM YOU
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
G.O.P. MEMO DETAILS HOW THE
FISA APPLICATION WRITTEN BY
ARTICLE WRITTEN BY CARTER
PAGE WHAT SCHIFF LIES ABOUT
IS THAT STEELE WAS THE
SOURCE FOR ISIKOFF AND YAHOO
NEWS WHICH THE FISA JUDGE
WAS NOT MADE AWARE OF.
HE IS LIKE THINKING THESE
ARE TWO INDEPENDENT
CORROBORATING SOURCES.
NO, ONE SOURCE, SAME PERSON.
AND THE REPUBLICAN MEMOS
EXPLAIN HOW THE YAHOO NEWS
ARTICLE WAS USED TO
INDEPENDENTLY CORROBORATE
STEELE DOSSIER AND OTHER
SOURCE BUT STEELE WAS THE
ONLY SOURCE.
ANOTHER LIED TO THE JUDGE.
ANOTHER YET KEY ASPECT OF
ALL OF THIS IS THE SCHIFF
MEMO IS ADMITTING TO BE
TRUE.
THE FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE REMEMBER,
WHY WAS HE TERMINATED AS AN
FBI SOURCE?
OH, HE WAS LEAKING TO THE
MEDIA WHAT SCHIFF
CONVENIENTLY LEAVE OUT
STEELE LIED TO THE FBI ABOUT
TALKING TO THE PRESS AND
BRINGING INFORMATION TO THEM
WHICH IS WHY SENATOR
GRASSLEY AND SENATOR GRAHAM
HAVE MADE A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
THE SCHIFF MEMO IS FULL OF
OTHER MASSIVE AND OUTRIGHT
LIES AS WELL.
FOR EXAMPLE, SCHIFF FALSELY
CLAIMS THAT CARTER PAGE WAS
NEVER SPIED ON.
WHILE THE MEMBER OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
BECAUSE WITH THE FISA
WARRANT, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THE ABILITY
TO ACCESS ALL OF PAGE'S OLD
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS.
ALL THE EMAILS.
OLD TEXT MESSAGES OLD PHONE
CALLS WHEN HE WAS PART OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE FBI SPIED ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND GETTING THE
WARRANT ON PAGE ALLOWED THEM
TO DO IT WHICH IS WHY THEY
LIED TO GET THE FISA
WARRANTS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
PAGE WILL JOIN US AND
EXPLAIN LATER ON.
NOW, IF THE GUY WAS A
RUSSIAN SPY.
CARTER PAGE, LIKE THE SCHIFF
MEMO IS CLAIMING.
WHY WASN'T CARTER PAGE BEEN
CHARGED WITH A CRIME?
IF THE EVIDENCE AGAINST PAGE
IS SO OVERWHELMING, YOU
KNOW, THAT THE FBI DIDN'T
NEED THE PHONY DOSSIER TO
GET A WARRANT.
AGAIN, JUST LIKE SCHIFF AND
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CLAIMING,
THEN WHY WAS IT USED?
NOW, SCHIFF WRITES THAT
CARTER PAGE ACTUALLY TALKED
TO THE FBI IN MARCH OF 2016.
AFTER THE FBI GOT THE
DOSSIER, MONTHS LATER WHY
WOULDN'T THEY JUST GO TO
TALK TO PAGE AGAIN AND FIND
OUT WHAT HE KNEW.
HE COOPERATED IN MARCH.
GETTING A FISA WARRANT ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN IS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE LAST RESORT.
IT SHOULD ONLY BE NECESSARY
WHEN THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS SEEKING CANNOT
BE OBTAINED THROUGH NORMAL
INVESTIGATIVE TECHNIQUES.
FROM WHAT WE NOW KNOW, THE
FBI DIDN'T GET IN CONTACT
WITH PAGE AGAIN WHEN THE
BUREAU APPARENTLY GOT THEIR
HANDS ON THE PHONY DOSSIER
IN THE FALL OF 2016 ONLY
MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
NOW, WHY WOULDN'T THE FBI DO
THAT WHEN PAGE HAD ALREADY
BEEN CORROBORATING?
NONE OF THIS MAKES SENSE.
AND THEN AGAIN MAYBE IT
ISN'T SUPPOSED TO BECAUSE
THE TRUTH IS FINALLY COMING
OUT.
HERE IS THE BOTTOM LINE, THE
FBI TOP ECHELON NOT RANK AND
FILE LIED TO A FISA JUDGE
ABOUT CLINTON AND THE DNC.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE
THAT SHE PAID FOR THESE
RUSSIAN LIES IN THIS DOSSIER
THAT WAS THEN USED TO GET A
WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP